tour de france après l'abandon dino
raymond mars un triomphe dans les
pyrénées l' enquête sur la ferme ory la
rivière les policiers seraient sur la
piste des ravisseurs
durée du travail la cfdt dit non les
négociations pourraient reprendre à
l'automne
madame monsieur bonsoir
les policiers sont maintenant sur les
traces des ravisseurs de monsieur maury
laribière et l' enquête s'est d'ailleurs
déplacé vers la région parisienne où une
voiture a été retrouvée
ayant appartenu aux auteurs de ce rapt
mais aujourd'hui à confolens dans les
charentes la famille maury laribière
était tout à la joie de se retrouver
enfin réunis c'est dans sa propriété
qu'il a regagné après 11 jours de
détention que là nous envoyés spéciaux
françois korber à rencontrer les
principaux acteurs de cette affaire si
maury laribière son fils aîné jean luc
qui a mené les tractations et le
commissaire gévaudan chargée de
l'enquêté
mais avant les premières images de
monsieur maury laribière retrouvant cet
après midi son usine et ses employés
c'est en début d'après midi que michel
maury laribière arrive dans son usine de
roumazières les employés retrouvent
leurs patrons c'est l'émotion des deux
côtés je crois fondamentalement comme
enlever pour l'argent mais étant donné
qu'à plusieurs reprises
on m'a dit sur des messages comme mon
cadavre et la publicité qui serait faite
autour de mon cadavre serait plus
important pour eux que l'art que la
rançon
alors j'avais je savais plus très bien
ce qui ce qu'il fallait penser
ils nous ont parlé d'une organisation
dont il faisait partie m'ont dit qu'ils
avaient une organisation extrêmement
puissante plus puissante que la police
qui ne pourraient strictement rien qui
vous a enlevé alors des amateurs ou de
véritables professionnels du grand
banditisme est ce que vous avez pu
donner à la police un signalement précis
de vos ravisseurs jamais vu la tête qui
que ce soit monsieur même quand j'ai été
même quand j'ai été arrêté à ma voiture
on m'a projetée comme vous savez un
liquide sur les yeux et je ne je n'ai
pas pu voir qu'ils qui m'a arrêté je
n'ai jamais vu une tête humaine
même quand je suis allé téléphoner
j'avais l'ordre de baisser les yeux de
ne pas regarder la personne qui était
avec moi est d'avoir la tête sous le
pare brise au moment où on arrivait près
de la cabine téléphonique
j'ai pitié pour eux en arriver à des
solutions comme ça et je leur pardonne
le crime qu'ils ont failli commettre
mais quand j'ai trouvé la lettre et la
voiture le samedi matin
je suis venu directement ici et
dans la minute qui a suivi avec ma mère
nous avons décidé de prévenir la police
et de jouer le jeu avec la police et par
la suite évidemment on est assailli d'un
certain nombre de sentiments
contradictoires mais personnellement je
me suis immédiatement fixé trois
objectifs le premier c'était de libérer
mon père le plus vite possible et en
bonne santé
le second c'était de tout faire pour
faire prendre les ravisseurs et le
troisième c'est de ne pas payer la
rançon ce que je voulais c'est un moyen
de savoir qu'ils étaient vivants pour
engager le processus suivant et essayer
en demandant des explications
complémentaires en faisant durer les
appels téléphoniques en demandant des
der contact de nouveaux contacts les
amener à faire une faute qui nous
permettraient les localiser c'était
difficile ce je savais qu'il y avait mon
père qui était derrière et kiki endurer
ce qu'elle a enduré
mais tout le monde m'a soutenu dans
cette dans cette décision en essayer de
l'amener jusqu'au bout et je pense que
c'était la bonne nous avons compris que
la famille ait accepté de collaborer
avec la police
nous avons pensé qu'il était peut-être
bon que l'on croit le contraire
alors justement vous avez berné tout le
monde dans la cia et ça réussit eh bien
oui pour tout le monde aussi
alors comment vous y êtes-vous pris
exactement sur le plan technique pour
verrouiller tout le monde ça peut être
difficile ya pas technique là dans la
rue manuel d'un côté qui a joué sarlat à
merveille et je crois qu'il est déjà
marié comédiens quelques vins et puis il
y avait moi qui disais à la presse vous
avez entendu je ne crois pas que la peau
est d'ailleurs été coupé complètement
caduque le sujet disait il arrivait
beaucoup de renseignements parce que les
français en général aiment bien leur
police quoi qu'on en dise et les
français de cette région vous coupez les
en envoyant des renseignements en toute
bonne foi et en pensant ils étaient tous
là bien évidemment ils n'étaient pas
tous nous ne pouvions pas nous exploiter
tous les renseignements qui vous arrive
est par contre tout ce qui sont arrivés
concernant le petit périmètre que nous
avions circonscrit étaient des
rationnements à exploiter d'urgence
parmi lesquels ce renseignement
concernant la maison de saint tin horse
que nous avons exploité des débuts de
notre opération de mercredi matin le
mobile
je ne connais pas encore mais quel qu'il
soit il reste que c'est une affaire
crapuleuse n'impose pas fait parce que
non je ne pense pas je ne peux pas vous
dévoiler tout ça n'est pas c'est une
enquête qui connaissent pas et qui ne se
terminera qu'avec l'arrestation débuté
dans le dire on va les appeler autrement
mais on prend tôt voir là dedans la main
aucune organisation connue non je crois
que maintenant on peut toujours
évidemment coloré d'aboville politique
ça c'est beaucoup maintenant mais il
faut pas y croire en fait on sait
aujourd'hui combien de laisser entendre
monsieur gévaudan que la police avait
donc tout mis en oeuvre pour retrouver
monsieur maury laribière jamais
peut-être d'aussi important effectif
n'avait été déployé une centaine
d'inspecteurs 400 gendarmes
cent trente techniciens du téléphone
chargé des écoutes et sur ordre direct
du premier ministre ce qui a permis
d'ailleurs de localiser l'endroit où
était séquestrée monsieur maury
laribière une cinquantaine de véhicules
encore un hélicoptère radars etc etc
et puis puis aussi le flair du gendarme
narcisse martin un gendarme à la
retraite qui a prévenu ses collègues du
comportement bizarre d'un certain nombre
d'individus opérant des allées venues
autour de la villa où on a finit
d'ailleurs par découvrir le vice
président du cnpf je pensais le centers
et je suis retraité de la gendarmerie
alors on émules trouver et j'ai alerté
l'agent michael ont aussitôt qu'elles
sont venues et oui ça s'appelle est très
longue
d'ici là la dame qui occupaient les
lieux n'ont pas dit non pas du tout je
connais très bien les lieux mais elle
vous avez vous avez d'autres d'autres
soupçons sur les lieux zaü su bel et
bien c'est très bien placé pour cacher
quelqu'un c'est vrai ça que vous me suis
déjà alerté la brigade quoi oui mais
vous savez que c'était monsieur ries la
rivière je m'en suis douté je me suis
douté mais y avait une pièce qui était
restée terne et julie là on cache
quelqu'un mais celui ô combien vaut
mille anonymes alors service service
même à la retraite
l'enquète s'est donc déplacé vers la
région parisienne depuis hier en effet
hier après midi une voiture repérée
comme étant l'un des véhicules utilisés
par les ravisseurs a été retrouvé
abandonné dans le parking des
champs-elysées où un rendez-vous dyer
avait été fixé dans la soirée entre les
gangsters et monsieur jean luc maury
laribière le fils aîné de monsieur maury
laribière c'est la libération en début
d'après-midi de monsieur maury laribière
qui a fait échouer la souricière tendue
par les policiers dans ce parc
pour l'instant deux hommes sont
recherchés la femme qui avait été arrêté
dans la villa est toujours interrogé par
les policiers et une vingtaine de
personnes interpellées hier à paris ont
été relâchées dans la matinale a donc
pour le point sur cette affaire
ce soit bon le départ c'est l'impression
que laisse l'abandon de bernard hinault
dans le tour de france jusqu'au dernier
moment hier soir le maillot jaune avait
gardé le secret le sourire même et puis
vers 22 heures il annonçait son abandon
avant de prendre la route en famille
pour la ville de lourdes
avant de regagner la bretagne cette
fameuse tendinite du genou qui a fait
parler toute la france est elle vraiment
à l'origine de cet abandon
bernard hinault dit que oui mais tout le
monde n'est pas convaincu enfin tout
avait commencé à l'arrivée de la fameuse
étape de gilles le 1er juillet à lille
ce jour là sous la pluie et sur les
pavés hinault remporté l'état ce bel
effort ils allaient le payer
ce que le lendemain il souffrait de
cette tendinite au genou le 3 in juillet
lowe's le visage marqué les traits tirés
envisagé même l'abandon qui peut passer
par différents stades successifs de
gravité croissante et nous l'avons la
chance de se traitait au stade st ou les
tendances on peut atteint mais avec le
traitement hilbert permet une
récupération rapide après cette
déclaration rassurante on doutait de la
gravité de la blessure dino le mardi il
terminait 5e du contre-la-montre
individuel le lendemain il se montrait
satisfait et pourtant quelques heures
plus tard on apprend dès son abandon
un abandon un peu étrange mais je pense
que vu la journée que je passe
aujourd'hui enfin raison que je
m'inquiète que dans les étapes qui
viennent bon ben je peux encore limiteur
la casse et puis bon ben il reste encore
deux étapes avant la montagne la grande
montagne dans les alpes donc je crois
que les possible de faire encore bien
les choses bernard voulait parti en
dehors de tout public
les jeunes ils sont là quand ça marche
bien parce que ça marche mal et ben
c'est peut-être la première fois que
bernard fuit ses responsabilités de
champion sous les montants gérés au
contraire verner n'a pas d'élu
absolument subir ce que j'étais revêt la
curée intrigue il me sert du coureur qui
abandonnent tout le monde se jette
dessus pour avoir la première l'arn pour
avoir la première déclaration et bernard
n'a pas voulu supporter ça qui est il
prévenu sans sa décision en tout le
monde dans l'équipe tv
oui quand je vous disais que cette
affaire est une affaire nationale
monsieur georges marchais qui assistait
aujourd'hui à l'arrivée à pau a déclaré
l'abandon de bernard hinault me fait
beaucoup de peine
la déclaration de monsieur marché sur
ligne d'arrivée ce soir en l'absence de
bernard hinault la première grande étape
de montagne dans les pyrénées
aujourd'hui a donné lieu à une grande
explication entre ces challenger qui
retrouve désormais toutes leurs chances
résultat deux abandons jan raas et
bertin un vainqueur d'étape le français
raymond martin et un nouveau maillot
jaune
le landais zoetemelk la grande étape des
pyrénées a donc tenu ses promesses les
quatre grands cols on fait exploser le
peloton de nombreux abandons race bertin
mêlée mais cette 13e étape a permis au
français raymond martin de se distinguer
en remportant cette course après une
très belle échappée solitaire il est
arrivé ainsi à luchon avec trois minutes
14 secondes d'avancé sur son coéquipier
le suédois nilsson et avec 3 minutes 30
secondes d'avancé sur un groupe
comprenant 16 l'aic agostino zoetemelk
la cfdt repousse le projet d'accord sur
la durée du travail proposé par le cnpf
la cfdt qui a été la dernière des
grandes centrales syndicales à prendre
position aujourd'hui a sorti sa réponse
d'une contre-proposition qui éviterait
d'anéantir deux années de discussions
jacques merlino a rencontré monsieur
à l'occasion de la conférence de presse
eh bien nous croyons qu'un accord est
possible si d'abord et en tout premier
lieu les modifications nécessaires de la
ouate 36 pour aménager le temps de
travail permettent une certaine
souplesse que les hommes et les femmes
puissent par exemple disposer un peu de
jours de congés de temps possible
cette modification de loi 36 ne peut pas
être laissée au seul bon vouloir du
patronat il faut que les syndicats la
contrôler la négocier et deuxièmement il
faut que les inégalités les plus graves
en matière de durée du travail soient
réduites
une façon plus significative qu'on
n'attende pas 83 pour donner cinq jours
de congés supplémentaires ou car auteur
à tous les salariés des petites
entreprises est plus aussi que ceux qui
ont des travaux pénibles soit
effectivement voit effectivement leur
durée du travail réduit nous croyons sur
ces propositions
il y a la possibilité d'aboutir à un
accord en tout cas c'est notre volonté
la balle est donc maintenant dans le
camp du patronat qui devra dire si ses
contre-propositions lui semble ou non
acceptable sans préjuger de sa réponse
s'il est au moins une évidence c'est que
le cnpf devra se donner un certain délai
de réflexion
d'abord parce que la semaine dernière il
avait déclaré être allé à la limite
extrême des concessions et que l'on ne
comprendrait pas qu'en quelques jours du
change d'avis ensuite parce qu'il faudra
de nouveau consulté ces différentes
instances et convaincre les nombreux
petits patrons qui ne sont pas très
chauds pour réduire la durée du travail
ce n'est donc qu'en septembre prochain
que nous saurons si cette négociation
qui dure déjà depuis 200 peut arriver un
terme définitif oui à propos de cette
négociation on apprend ce soir que les
petites et moyennes entreprises ne pose
pas de conditions à une reprise d'une
discussion sur la durée du temps de
travail par contre monsieur seguin qui
est un député des vosges propose lui que
cette affaire soit portée devant le
parlement et puis pour en revenir à la
conférence de presse que donné cet après
midi monsieur edmond maire chesneau
maire indiqué que selon lui la cfdt
estime que la cgt a tiré un trait sur
l'accord d'unité d'action qui avait été
signé entre les deux grandes centrales
syndicales françaises en 1974 et cela la
suite des différentes critiques qu'a
fait monsieur séguy de l'action de
monsieur edmond maire lui-même et de son
de sa centrale syndicale en général
restructuration dans l'industrie
chimique rhône poulenc a décidé de céder
sa chimie lourde au groupe pétrolier
d'état elf aquitaine cette transaction
qui porte sur près de 2 milliards de
francs devrait permettre à rhône poulenc
de développer sa branche chimie fine
biologie et pharmacie une
restructuration qui concerne huit cent
quarante mille travailleurs et qui est
déjà très critiqué par la cgt 52% des
médecins prêts à adhérer à la convention
qui vient d'être signée avec les caisses
de sécurité sociale cela selon un
sondage réalisé pour l'hebdomadaire
médical tonus par la sofres 28 % des
médecins interrogés refusent cette
convention 20% sont encore hésitants
rappelons que pour l'instant la
confédération des syndicats médicaux
majoritaire chez les médecins refusent
d'adhérer à cette convention il faut y
ajouter ce soir une déclaration de
monsieur barreaux le ministre de la
santé au journal ouest france monsieur
barreau qui estime que cette convention
qui vient d'être signée ne peut être
renégociés à faire de vraies la
commission parlementaire spéciale
entendra finalement l'inspecteur rouge
ce policier qui affirme avoir averti ses
supérieurs des menaces de mort pesant
sur le prince de brouille monsieur
longuet le rapporteur la commission a
expliqué qu'il avait accepté cette
audition cas toute la presse et
l'opinion publique
on était informé des déclarations
d'inspecteurs où l on ne comprendrait
pas où l'on comprendrait mal que nous ne
voulions pas l'entendre à notre tour
un comité national de soutien à l'action
de monsieur michel debré vient d'être
créé sa tête on retrouve monsieur jean
emile vielles monsieur jacques le noir
et monsieur jean-marie dedeyan la visite
officielle le monsieur giscard d'estaing
république fédérale allemande s'est
poursuivie aujourd'hui par un sommet
entre messieurs schmitt monsieur giscard
d'estaing entourés de leurs principaux
mise à l'ordre du jour la détente et les
problèmes économiques de bonne
notre envoyé spécial michel meyer
objectif inchangé pour les deux hommes
d'état amis à rétablir le dialogue est
ouest tout en donnant à l'europe les
moyens concrets d'assumer de plus en
plus sa propre sécurité
sa propre protection à cet égard
l'annnonce de bombes à neutrons
française et de modernisation de
l'arsenal nucléaire suscite du côté
allemand des espoirs que l'on préfère ne
pas trop afficher l'économie elle aussi
omniprésente avec la volonté d'ancrer
plus encore la solidarité monétaire et
économique entre européens entre
économies européennes tout à fait
interdépendantes et cela de façon
irréversible avec aussi l'intention de
prendre des mesures contre l'invasion
buvait dangereusement excessive des
produits japonais automobile notamment
sur le marché européen
un programme qui ne se limitera pas là
la présence de presque tout le
gouvernement français à bonn en est un
signe et on peut déjà parler pour demain
matin de la réunion d'un véritable
conseil des ministres franco allemand
en attendant dès ce midi une visite à
l'office franco allemand pour la
jeunesse un organisme qui depuis sa
création il ya dix sept ans a permis à
quelques 4 millions de jeunes français
et allemands de se découvrir et de
découvrir le pays voisin
ce qui pour le président ne suffit pas
encore dans ce court voyage
fm le président la république fédérale
j'ai vu que nous avions encore beaucoup
à faire et que nous avions
apparemment résolu les problèmes
politiques c'est vrai mais du côté
culturel il votait la connaissance
mutuelle
nous avons encore de très grands progrès
à accomplir et je souhaite que votre
génération qui ne sera donc plus de
toute façon la génération de la guerre
c'est quelque chose qui a disparu pour
toujours de nos relations soient la
première génération à faire progresser
de façon très très approfondie et
j'espère très enthousiaste la
connaissance réciproque de la culture et
de l'âme allemande et française oui
justement en rapport avec ce que vient
de dire le président un public on
apprend ce soir que trois accords
culturel viennent de signer aujourd'hui
entre la france et l'allemagne accord
destiné à faciliter la scolarité des
jeunes français et allemands étudiants
dans l'un et l'autre pays
mise à part la politique et le thème
plusieurs fois répété par monsieur
schmitt des giscard d'estaing d'une
nécessaire coopération franco-allemande
pour rendre à l'europe son importance
dans le monde ce qui a frappé beaucoup
de journalistes pendant cette visite
c'est la chaleur de l'accueil réservé
par la population allemande au président
français au cours de sa visite le
président valéry giscard d'estaing
voulais sentir ce que l'on peut appeler
l'allemagne de tous les goûts il n'a pas
été déçu car du nord au sud
une foule dense curieux et chaleureuse
était au rendez vous
oui
à chaque étape du voyage le même
enthousiasme communicatif au point
d'entraîner madame giscard d'estaing a
recherché et l'oci de contact avec les
citoyens de l'ue baisse
en ce domaine foule rendez-vous stoïque
avec les averses qui accompagnaient les
parades militaires
invité exceptionnel un chancelier
schmick qui avait retrouvé sa casquette
de marin pêcheur et son salut militaire
d'anciens officiers de charge et de
ministres les armées
sa présence au front des troupes
françaises avec le président français a
eu la valeur d'un symbole très remarquée
à un moment où est relancé en europe un
débat sur la sécurité
très vite pourtant retour liesse
populaire bavaroise en compagnie du
bavarois franz josef strauss
l'adversaire électorale centre au sens
de la consécration aussi par le timbre
d'une visite qui fut celle d'une
évidente normalité de relations entre
français et allemands franco-allemande
et cette visite c'est important pour
vous cela signifie pour vous consacrer
les français en allemand en iront
l'amiral madani ancien candidat à la
présidence de la république iranienne
entre en rébellion ouverte contre
l'actuel gouvernement il refuse en effet
de siéger au parlement islamique
par ailleurs on annonce à téhéran la
nomination très prochainement d'un
premier ministre et puis ce soir le
président bani sadr est intervenu à la
radio iranienne pour dire qu'un complot
venette peuvent être déjoués les
négociations sur l'autonomie
palestinienne reprendront dimanche
prochain c'est ce qu'on annonce
aujourd'hui officieusement encore au
caire messieurs quintais rewaco aux fans
se sont donc rencontrés pour la première
fois la nuit dernière à tokyo et déjà
l'on parle d'un axe washington tokyo
pékin contre moscou mais avant son
départ le président carter a tenu à
souligner qu'il n'était en aucun cas
question d'une alliance militaire avec
la chine cette rencontre avait lieu
avait eu lieu je vous le rappelle à
l'occasion
les obsèques de l'ancien premier
ministre japonais monsieur rire patrick
clément
et oui les obsèques de monsieur hierà
n'ont été qu'un protège carter juste
avant de quitter le japon
lorsqu'il est sur l'amiante à deux
confrères de la nhk ne suis même pas
allusion ce président américain rentrer
à tout de suite dans le vif du sujet en
expliquant au cours de cette interview
que les bonnes relations entre la chine
le japon et les etats-unis ne devaient
pas être comprise comme une menace
contre l'ennui soviétique allons donc
cela n'est que précautions oratoires
puisque l'essentiel de ce sommet a
tourné sur la confirmation d'une
alliance circulaire washington tokyo
pk alliance accélérée par les événements
d'afghanistan les affrontements en
thaïlande vietnam tout cela évidemment
concerne directement la présence
soviétique dans la région et les moyens
à contraindre wako fin et que l'on voit
ici tout sourire face à carter et sa
ravissante traductrice a réussi à donner
un caractère symbolique aux entretiens
si l'américain malgré japonais soucieux
tout de même de préserver leurs
relations avec moscou
mais carter à la fin de ces entretiens a
insisté sur l'amélioration des rapports
entre les trois pays il a peut-être
voulu faire comprendre reste l'humour
des à l'europe occidentale que tout de
même l'amérique est le pays le plus
puissant du monde la chine le plus
peuplé
le japon l'un des plus développés alors
l'entente entre ces trois puissances
admettons qu'elle ne soit que de
circonstance ramène sur beaucoup de
points muzaffar l'urss
le reste des relations internationales
au niveau des bavardages et péripéties
à peine rentrée à pékin monsieur hu
accompagné l'objet de rumeurs évoquant
une éventuelle démission de son poste de
premier ministre à l'occasion du
prochain plénum du parti communiste
chinois et cela au mois d'août monsieur
wegofunk quitterait son poste de premier
ministre pour ne gagner que ses
fonctions essentielles d'ailleurs de
président du parti communiste chinois
un million huit cent mille français
partent en vacances demain et durant
tout le week-end ces départs s'ajoutent
à ceux du week-end du 14 juillet c'est
dire que les risques de bouchons sont
importants conséquence
voici les conseils du célèbre et fameux
bison futé d'abord vendredi ensuite pour
samedi
les principales difficultés étant
attendus vendredi aux sorties des
grandes agglomérations samedi un peu
partout et puis plus spécialement
d'après les spécialistes sur la moitié
est de la france
si vous pouvez évitez donc de partir
vendredi samedi
de préférence partez dès ce soir ou
dimanche à condition bien sûr que vous
soyez disposé à perdre deux jours de
vacances ça ça se discute
les résultats du tiercé maintenant pour
gagner il fallait jouer le 2 le 10 et le
un rapport pour 5 francs sur votre écran
24 1837 francs dans l'ordre ordre
différent 4422 francs toujours pour 5
francs voilà l'heure fatidique de
laurent broomhead et de la météo
j'espère pour lui qu'il a de bonnes
nouvelles pour écouter non parce que
c'est pas très gai je crois que le temps
restera médiocre les prochains jours
médiocre pour la saison sur la majeure
partie du pays je voudrais vous signaler
toutefois que les statistiques viennent
de nous dire que la france vient de
battre un record mondial record mondial
de pluie 6433 millimètres d'eau tombés
en quinze jours le précédent record
appartenait achir apologie une petite
ville au pied de l'himalaya il faut dire
que ces six mètres d'eau tombés en
quinze jours ne sont pas tombés sur la
métropole mais sur l'île de la réunion
au moment au début de l'année du passage
du site longue hyacinthe
alors chez nous pas cyclone pas non plus
d'anticyclone ne pouvait très malade sur
les açores et toute l'europe baigne dans
des basses pressions ce qu'on appelle
les dépressions un tourbillon de mauvais
temps situé sur l'europe centrale
il envoie de l'air sur notre pays venant
du nord ouest de l'or de l'air frais et
très instable encore des averses demain
principalement de la manche orientale
haut rhin ou rouge au nord des alpes et
même du massif central
donc surtout le nord-est du pays plus au
sud ouest et au sud il fera tout de même
le meilleur des éclaircies un peu plus
belle après toutefois de la brume dans
l'aquitaine ainsi que sur les côtes de
l'atlantique
malheureusement la dépression de
l'europe centrale va recevoir du renfort
à partir du vendredi soir par l'ouest
voyez cette ligne de pluie qui arrivent
ici c'est une autre perturbation une
autre dépression elle donnera des nuages
dès l'après-midi sur la bretagne avec
même des petites pluies le soir pas
compliqué pour samedi prévoir le temps
est bien de la bretagne aux pyrénées
cette ligne de pluie arrivera le matin
et pénétrera sur le pays dans la journée
traversant tout le pays d'ouest en est
ce donc samedi pluvieux précéder tout de
même de belles éclaircies dans l'est
dans la journée
pour dimanche c'est bien ma foi
amélioration bien sûr après le passage
de cette ligne depuis bien nous
retrouverons un temps instable un peu
plus chaud tout de même on croira
peut-être que c'est l'été peut même des
nuages dans le ciel mais selon toute
vraisemblance le scénario devrait
continuer d'autres nuages pourraient
suivre si bien que les pétards du 14
juillet devraient être peut-être un
petit peu mouillé en particulier sur
l'ouest du pays
enfin nous verrons bien nous pouvons
espérer quand vous le voyez le temps de
ce week-end n'est pas très agréable
et si la dépression et sur la france
elle est aussi bien dans la carte
météorologique que dans l'esprit des
vacanciers aussi bien dans le nord que
dans le sud du pays je vous propose
d'ailleurs de regarder quelques images
qui nous viennent de l'atlantique
excepté les pêcheurs au bord de
l'atlantique tout le monde à froid
l'océan reste incroyablement désert et
personne n'ose le regardais pas de
nuages pour ceux qui vendent duvet
canadienne ou ciré mais pour les autres
l'horizon est complètement bouché
saison avait pas bonne du tout je crois
qu'elle est même catastrophique pour
nous parce que le commerce souffre
terriblement de sept ans pour ceux qui
campent les affaires ne sont guère plus
florissante les plus démoralisée décide
de s'en aller ils tentent leur chance en
se dirigeant vers la méditerranée
quant aux autres ceux qui restent ils
ont de bonnes raisons
enseignant je demande une latence donc
temps de voir quoi
alors soyez enseignants en sabots ou
emmitouflés
voilà ce journal est terminée je vous
signale encore que demain l'invité
d'antenne 2010 sera monsieur claude
guillemin géologue avec qui le
découvriront le travail auquel se
livrent les géologues français du bureau
de recherche biologique et minières le
célèbre berger puis je ne voudrais pas
pour terminer vous démoraliser
complètement mais je vous propose tout
de même de terminer ce journal sur des
images filmées aujourd'hui à paris où il
faisait à peine 17 degrés il faisait
même moins que ça à lille et à nancy 12
degrés et simplement 24 à marseille et
oui on est en juillet je vais vérifier
ici avant de descendre sur mon
calendrier
bonsoir et bon moral quand même au
revoir
à